[Music]
hello there
and uh
thank you for being here and thank you
for existing as is the motto of this
conference apparently
uh my name is mature
and if you cannot pronounce french
sounds you can call me matt or whatever
like i don't care
but um
i am a front-end developer and i work
for talon
in berlin
and we do a promotion engine and if
you're interested in knowing what a
promotion engine is i invite you to
visit our site which is talent.one
and if you want to know more about me
you can go there and you will know
way too much about me
but
as a front-end developer i spend a lot
of time thinking about one thing
what makes users feel good because
this is kind of my job i just talk with
product designers and product owners and
we define
how we can make the users of our
products feel the best they can
and so i want you kind of to think about
it what makes users feel good
and you can keep it to yourself and make
a little list in your mind or you can
shout it with reckless abandon and maybe
i'll talk about it so what makes user
feel good
great ui that is true
speed that is true as well
and
sorry
big buttons i i do love a big button
like
that is actually the best feeling
so yeah
uh
indeed like um the first thing
sorry
proper api that is also for i guess api
first product the best
so yeah
uh
so i want to talk about a few things uh
at a pretty conceptual level about what
makes user feel good first
we have heard it speed
because users they want things to load
fast they want things to react fast and
that is pretty straightforward
but further they want things to be
predictable they want to not be
astonished as the saying goes
because
you know you do a thing
and you expect it to behave like the
thousands of other things that look
exactly the same
but more than predictable they want
something to be reliable
and that means it is not broken which is
sometimes surprisingly rare to find
but yeah not broken and up the most time
it can
and finally the most subjective thing
and the harder to get is the light and
that is hard to get because
what this means is that a user wants to
keep using your app even when they don't
have to because it feels good and that's
why big buttons are important like
it just feels good
uh so that has that kind of like is
always in my mind
but as a tech leads at 101 there's
another thing that is always on my mind
and that's
what makes developers feel bad because i
don't want people to be unhappy i just
want everyone to enjoy the best life
they can and you know that's not always
possible but we can make it better
so
same as before do you want to think a
little bit about why you feel bad and
introspect a little
and all
shout your pain to the world to hear
like you can do it now like
oh so many people are wanting to shout
by pain it's awesome like okay go ahead
bad documentation that is for sure a
pain that we all have failed
sorry managers
sorry i'm not talking about managers
here like i'm a pretty diplomatic guy
like
so yeah
clients clients are same i'm not going
to get into fight with customers and
clients but
small buttons
i cannot believe that uh
them
now i'm thinking of all the small
buttons i actually created in my life
and i feel extremely bad but that's fine
because we're going to fix it so um
what makes the developers feel bad i
will say that it is first like an
absence of speed
so that is that can happen at every
level of your experience as a developer
so before you write the code because
like the tasks are well defined and you
have to have so much back and forth
during the code because your build time
is super slow or your rebuild time is
super slow or both and you're very sad
and after the code where
you are waiting for two weeks for your
pr to be reviewed and no one cares and
that also makes you very sad
but
and i think you are seeing where i'm
going for uh
the absence of predictability and that's
when you find yourself during your work
day asking why
a lot
way too much and no one can help you
because there is no answer to this why
why is this the way it is
because it is
this is not helpful and very you know
existentially painful
so
then
what the developer
is miserable about is of course
the absence of reliability
and that is when stuff breaks you fix a
bug five times it's still breaking and
you don't know why your ci is throwing
errors and you don't know why either
this is
terrible you just want things to run
smoothly
and finally
arguably all of this is not delightful
at all
and but
more than this
it is
making you feel isolated and
really kind of
resignation
it makes you resign to the pain you're
feeling and that is like definitely an
absence of delight
so
what can we do about this
because
all of these experiments i described
not everyone feels them
and not everyone feels them the same way
but it is kind of a shared experience of
feeling bad about some part of our work
so
the way we can make it better
is the topic of this talk
dx is ux or more ex
more explicitly
dx as ux
yeah i said the name of the thing
so we think a lot about providing our
users with the best experience possible
but we should also think about providing
ourselves with the best user experience
possible for all of the things that we
use and that we make
so we want a fast predictable reliable
delightful experience and we can have it
if we put some effort in
this is of course a bunch of opinions of
course like i'm a front-end developer i
work mostly with javascript and
typescript and react
and it's not of course going to be
you know a guide a step-by-step
set of lessons to make your life
magically better but it is going to give
you some kind of map
of areas where you can actually
explore and maybe find things to make
your life better
and my hope is that
throughout this talk you're going to
just maybe latch on some stuff that
you're going to bring to your work next
week and just like start some kind of dx
movement
and
actually maybe nothing in this talk is
going to be new to you and actually
actually a lot of talks that we have
heard yesterday and today
kind of relate to what i'm going to talk
about
but it's all about reframing it and
applying it to your life
so let's dive in and
make it fast
because if we're going to be in pain at
least it should be for a short time
so
yeah
so um
let's start right away
with the build tools which is kind of
like the first first thing that anyone
any developer would think about when you
say like yeah yeah let's make it faster
and it is
a very good entry because it is a very
clear goal that you can measure
and you can feel good about it very
easily
so your belt time was seven minutes you
did some stuff in webpack or you changed
to viet and now it's like 30 seconds
that is amazing
but it is a big investment
and
not everyone has the resources for it
so some other things that you can
improve except for the tools is the
processes
and continuous delivery
is a
principle
which is
a little like it has a lot of stuff in
it but the core of it is that everything
that gets merged to the main branch is
immediately deployed for all your users
and this
has a lot of beneficial side effects
like you are going to naturally find
yourself making smaller changes more
incremental prs stuff is reviewed faster
because you're you know it's easier to
review 100 lines than 10 000
and you can iterate faster on your
features
so
that is mechanically going to maybe not
be faster but feel faster and that is
almost the same as anyone that
implemented a fake
loader will tell you on the big button
so
then
after we have like the well the
well-defined tasks
because i do enjoy intellectually
stimulating conversation with product
designer and product owners so that we
can really lock down what we want but
these conversation needs to happen at a
specific time not
several times during their lifetime of
future deployment
and
if you do not uh define these early it's
going to just hold your progress many
times like a
multiple bottlenecks and that does feel
bad
and finally
we
know that reviews are important we have
heard about it in this conference
and if you care about code quality and
knowledge sharing which is in my opinion
the two main
role of a code review you will implement
some kind of process because
if you don't uh there is like a
universal law of code bases where like
reviews are going to be made by two
people and the rest are never going to
review anything so yeah just implement
something everyone should know who
reviews what when and there are
automated ways to do this or you can
just talk with your colleagues and agree
on something which is a novel
concept
so
from all of this what we can say is that
speed is about code and it's also about
humans because you can optimize the
hardware and software a lot
but the wetware of humans also
contribute to the speed of development
and ideally we should all want to feel
like rob
and
rob is super happy because he has
implemented turbo repo in his monorepo
and his build time has been decreased by
i don't know like 80 it's amazing and he
has used this little astonished emoji
and i literally want to tweet the same
thing
unfortunately we're still using webpack
but
uh
that is like the the goal
this feeling
but now that it's fast we have to keep
it that way and
to keep it that way you have to make it
standard
to have a predictable experience
no one wants to argue about certain
things in a code base and some of these
things are semicolon and
quotes
so
you should just choose prettier for
formatting your code like
at this point in javascript it's like
i think not optional like you just
use prettier maybe change a few things
in the config make it mandatory make it
format and save never think about this
again
but
further
code linting is
essential and linting is not formatting
because formatting is how it looks
linting is what it does and how
so
my personal preference for code linting
is using eslint like
the pers like the
the standard tool that it is
and
use the minimum amount of rules
and just
along the way add the one that you feel
are
essential and eventually you end up like
airbnb with 15 000 rules that everybody
hates
but
that is actually a bad outcome you
should stop
before you reach that time
but yeah like
more standard things that we need
are libraries
because you know javascript is an
amazing language
where you can do anything in any way you
want
and also javascript is a terrible
language where you can do anything in
any way you want
and so that is especially painful when
you are working with dates or numbers or
that efficient any number of things that
should be in a standard library and that
we don't have
maybe after type annotations comes in so
like in 30 years maybe so yeah
in the meanwhile just pick one library
to standardize your numbers and dates
and stuff
and just use that one
it doesn't have to be the best library
it just have to be the one you use
and finally
documentation
and so last words but not least as we
say and i mean documentation in the
widest sense possible
because it is of course written
documents but it's also comments it's
also thoughtful naming of functions
uh that we saw in the talk as well like
yesterday
and it's also just like
all the ways that you can do it so that
someone that comes into your code
knows how to find the information they
need
so
predictability
is having one way to do things and that
is a terribly absolute thing to say and
i actually don't
agree entirely but the spirit
is
to remove ambiguity if you have two ways
to do a thing and they're equal in all
respect except for like some cosmetics
just do it one way and
have less headaches
and i want us to look at something
pretty quick
this absolutely
banal and an eventful
exchange it is from the article from the
remote.com handbook
that's called culture of documentation
and it looks extremely
not interesting right
but to me it's extremely interesting
because
the implications that this exchange has
are great
the documentation was written it was
kept up to date it was easy to search
and retrieve the information
and it was easy to share it so all of
these things
i don't know if you've ever worked at a
place that had implemented such good
documentation for everything
but
i sure wish i did because this feels
absolutely delightful
so now stuff is fast stuff is um
predictable
but we also
need stuff to not break
so we need it to make it uh dependable
because broken things are very sad
and they should be detected and fixed as
soon as possible
but ideally they should not even break
in the first place
so how can we do this
we can do this first with
the thing that has one
which are types like as gil said in the
first talk of this conference
types you cannot avoid them anymore
and
the thing is that i as same as gil i
don't mean typescript necessarily
typescript is good but in react there
are prop types
in
there is also js docs that have type
annotations and if you want to wait a
few years you can use the standard type
annotations
but
more than types like what makes
your app reliable and your experience
better are tests
specifically automated tests again this
everyone agrees on you need them and you
need them for like small functions like
small pure functions you can use unit
tests if you want to test more complex
flows you can have like some integration
tests and if you have limited resources
and time you can have a full suit of e3
tests which gives you the best
confidence that are very expensive to
write and run because you actually
simulate a browser
so
this is very important
but what is also
equally important
is testing by humans i don't know if
there's like any qa engineers in the
room like raise your hands
no no one well
maybe you're too shy to raise your hand
but i see you and i love you thank you
so
uh yeah because for me like
we're not writing codes to pass a suite
of automated tests we write code for so
that humans can use our app and actually
achieve results and if no one has
checked that except for you when you
write a feature then
maybe reconsider you know merging it
so yeah and finally
reporting because
even if we implement all of these
perfectly
it will still be broken at some point
it's inevitable so you should know about
it and you should act on it
so
implement a monitoring tool have some
reporting either emails slack alerts any
way you want and pay attention to them
and have some kind of triage process so
that you can prioritize issues and just
make it so that your thing is not broken
and be happy
reliability
is minimizing risk and maximizing
response
because we cannot win against the
universal law of entropy we can only
get some scraps from their jaw and
be heroic when we just deliver something
that works for at least a little bit
so
airbnb actually reclaimed a lot from
entropy when they moved to typescript
like this talk is actually amazing it's
a bit old but it was given by a bree
bunch at jsconf hawaii and it was about
like how airbnb moved all their code
base to typescript and they had this
amazing
figure where they found out 38 of the
bugs they fixed were could be avoided
with typescript and i mean if that
doesn't convince you i don't know like
maybe like you just enjoy
living on the edge and i respect that
so yeah
now we have something that is fast
that is predictable that is reliable
but uh you know all of this is like very
uh business haha
and we also are developers and as lucky
said we like to have fun so
we should make it pleasant as well
because work is not pleasure
and in french the work for the word for
pleasure
the work for
the word for work is travail
and it comes from the latin word
which is
a torture instrument
with three spikes and i don't know what
the spikes are used for but i'm not very
curious and uh
you know it makes sense
but it's not all bad right like we can
still
try to have a little fun or at least
be
merry
in the jaws of the serpent so yeah
first we have to share
because our job is about knowledge
and sharing knowledge
and that's why i'm so happy to be in
this career because i just love sharing
random stuff with people and i love when
they share their random stuff with them
with me
and that's why i love conference as well
so much random stuff sharing all the
time it's great
so yeah
it's a privilege and we should abuse it
so
yeah
go ahead
but
even if it's so much fun
being a developer is also taxing
mentally and emotionally as we also have
seen in this conference so many great
talks
so what we need is support and i mean
giving support
and receiving support
that we need
and not everybody needs the same support
not everyone is receptive to a pair
programming session not everyone wants a
clear outline of all the steps to take
for resolving their problems
just
learn to know your colleagues and also
share the kind of support that you're
asking for when you are in difficulty
and then you will receive hopefully um
so yeah
that is the second thing that will make
your time more delightful
and thirdly
that is a principle that is quite common
not blaming when we break things because
we have seen it's inevitable there is no
point in blaming a single person for
breaking a thing what we should do is
find the systemic causes of this failure
and fix it together
and then
we can celebrate
this is like a thing that i realized
recently is that
when you get a bit experience you just
forget how hard things used to be
you just i remember very clearly that
the for-loop syntax really confused me
when i started developing i could not
make sense of it and now it's not even a
thought and it's like in the first first
brain like the psychology talk
we had
so yeah just
apply this also to your work environment
where you check out like a random
comment from two years ago and you
compare the state of the app now to the
state of the app then and you're like
wow we went to
a very long way nice
that is the best feeling
because delight is building our own
experience
oh
is it like the
it's been a while
why didn't you tell me
ah i don't even need slides i can talk
like this for all day
but yeah i don't know why it's like
broken
let's see
[Music]
where is it
then it's it's gone
it's gone
sorry sorry
yeah that's what i'm doing
yeah
i don't know
damn
let me
just do a thing
i'm just going to
take this put it oh no not wait a second
i'm sorry uh it will go
come on
okay
you're doing awesome
[Applause]
why is it not rendering
yeah i know like i think i'm very
[Applause]
and
this is why you don't choose random
javascript libraries to make your slides
but it's so much fun though like
which is the point
yeah exactly
okay let me go back the light is the
wrong color
i've never seen okay let's
continue
celebrate
the light is building our own experience
it's not necessarily the best experience
but it's ours like and we should just
be like this
exactly yeah like you earned this slide
right like you suffered through
no slides for a while now you get the
nice others and this is like kind of my
ideal state like just floating in a sea
of bliss having my little code base baby
and
just being happy
but it seems like a lot of work to do
all of this like i talked about a bunch
of stuff super superficially and you
know it seems
like a lot of work and i'm lazy
but it is a lot of work and that's why
you should not take it on yourself
individually to do it you should just
share and
define what is important to you so is it
speed is it reliability is it
predictability is it delight what is
important for you and your team just dig
into it and
lead the movement to make your life
better
because it is super worth it every
initiative you take to make your dx
better
is multiplicative with the others it's
like some kind of
exponential curve of happiness so you
know
everything i have done at time 1 to make
lives of others better has improved my
own life and
just do it
and
speaking of doing it i don't know if you
have scanned any of the qr codes that
that were on the slides that did not
show for half the things but
i've made a little website with a bunch
of resources that you can access
to kind of give you ideas of how to
implement the things i talked about and
you can also see like the the slides
and
thanks that was great
so awesome